let's talk about kyrie the kyrie thing
is really funny because uh
it just goes to show you like what
frauds people are i think we spoke about
this on the podcast i'm if i'm not
mistaken we did say it
but um
i mean like conservative media was
telling lebron to shut up and dribble
you're not allowed to be an activist how
dare you you should just be a basketball
player shut the [ __ ] up right
and
democrat media was saying how dare you
tell a basketball player to not be vocal
about what they believe in yeah not be
passionate about their opinions they're
allowed to have these opinions they'll
allow to support whatever they want to
support
yeah kyrie doesn't want to get
vaccinated all of a sudden that same
democrat liberal media is going shut up
and dribble
how dare you you don't [ __ ] know
anything shut your mouth yeah okay you
go play basketball that's what you do
right yeah and conservative media is
saying he should be allowed to voice his
opinions he's a person he should be
allowed to say whatever the [ __ ] he can
use his platform for whatever he likes
exactly 100 it just shows what absolute
frauds people are yes there is no
consistency and that's okay we're all
hypocrites we have to be hypocrites to
exist in the first world every single
one of us my issue is
with is managing the hypocrisy yeah is
major hypocrisy by suggestion don't
manage the hypocrisy by like
pointing out the absurdity of the other
side when you know you're about to
commit the exact same hypocrisy the next
week yeah you are as loyal as your
opinions and you do not move away from
your opinions at all because you know
that there's safety in numbers with your
opinions if you're conservative you've
got 50 of people that got your back no
matter what you say as long as it's with
the company line right and if you're
liberal you've got 50 of people in
country that got you back tomorrow
what'd you say as long as there's tone a
company line when you go and have your
own opinion about something you're going
to get all the [ __ ] pushback you're
going to get you're going to get ripped
apart yeah a car in the middle of the
road is getting run over by both sides
ooh is that a say you just somebody said
that to me one time oh it's really good
it was in like a [ __ ] uber this guy
said it to me it's really good yeah it's
not the best place to say that
he's like anyway so we'll turn left
but it is it is true it just shows what
[ __ ] absurd you know society we live
in man it's like yeah nobody's
consistent with anything but the company
line where they have their security they
just want the security they just want
people to pat them on the [ __ ] back
and the people that come out and have
their own unique opinion about every
different topic like charles barkley is
one of them yeah
we love charles and i think mainly for
this because we go he will say what he
feels yes he is honest he's honest
there's authenticity there and you feel
it yes and he doesn't care if he gets
pushed back he's very comforting yeah
it's amazing i trust you feel this and
you're saying this as opposed to anybody
on one of these news networks you're
like you're saying what your viewers
want to hear so you can keep your job
yes charles i said what he feels yeah
say some conservative [ __ ] say some
liberal [ __ ] say some dumb [ __ ] say some
funny [ __ ] say some smart smart [ __ ]
we're with it yeah it's you saying what
you feel talking from your heart let's
let's just do that does it frustrate you
like when you just see the
how how fraudulent news is like to me
that's the most blatant example of how
fraudulent news is obviously there's a
rogan situation but like this right here
is the exact
opinion yeah
you should just play sports and not have
an opinion on anything yeah and then
once the opinion is something that you
agree with
you are more than i'm so glad you're
yeah
you were more than an athlete
100 and to lebron's credit i'll say he
hasn't been saying anything about kyrie
and he's just like this is a decision
that was right for me which is kind of i
guess a safe thing to say corporate wise
or like whatever but like
yeah i don't how do you feel about what
kyrie is doing though
shut up and dribble
[Laughter]
no i mean that's i i feel that way
because that's what i would do i would
shut the [ __ ] up and dribble i would
just get the backs i got the backs right
i was like what's gonna make this easier
how do i go to restaurants how do i how
is my life easier i'll just get [ __ ]
backs i also thought there was some
fraudulence in i am trying to be the
voice for the voiceless
are these people who don't want to get
vaccines voiceless really because i hear
them a lot
i mean i don't think they're so
voiceless that's funny that's my whole
thing is like there's a lot of voiceless
people on earth this isn't one of them
right you know what i mean you just
don't want to get the facts and that's
fine but be honest do you think he
retrofitted his uh activism on yes
i don't want to i don't think he likes
basketball that much i don't think he
loves it he likes it i don't think he
loves it i don't think he's dying to win
i don't think he's dying to play which
is fine jordan is getting vacs kobe is
getting facts jordan is shooting every
one of his teammates with a vaccine
himself yeah
winning the championship yeah stick the
needle in your [ __ ] arm and that's
that was shaq's thing he didn't even say
anything scientific he was like if you
want to win get the [ __ ] vax for
trying to get a championship this is my
goal and shaq love basketball but not
even as much as a kobe or an mj yeah
yeah kyrie not even there yeah that's a
great point he doesn't care enough i
think he just doesn't he's really
[ __ ] good at basketball but he
doesn't love it yeah you don't miss it
it doesn't give him purpose and i think
that's why you might have i know you
find this purpose you've talked about
this with kyrie trying to find purpose
in everything i don't know if you said
it but it's probably because he doesn't
love basketball like that i never
thought about it like that in terms of
love of the game yeah i think that could
be it like he usually when you have
something that you're so passionate
about and that you absolutely love and a
goal is attached to it yeah that's
enough for you yeah and they struggle
after basketball because now they have
to go through this this monumental life
change where they don't have a carrot in
front of them that they're trying to
chase what's the new carrot and that's
why these athletes oftentimes fall apart
when they stop playing a game yeah but
he has the thing that should be the
carrot he has the purpose he has the
goal he has a thing that could take up
all his time and he can make
tens of millions if not hundreds of
millions of dollars doing it
but he must not love it enough yeah it's
not dude if i think if you're really
passionate about a thing you're probably
not that political because your passion
is channeled you have a singular focus
yeah yeah yeah none of us are that
political yeah political but not really
we're not that wrapped up in it because
we are passionate about comedy content
whatever it is that's my passion all
this other [ __ ] is kind of in the way of
it yeah
kyrie
basketball is not the thing he's not so
he's searching
this conspiracy theory might grab my
attention it might hold me it might be
the world is flat no it's not that oh
antibiotic i'm the voice for the
voiceless no you're not
i have to take games off because i you
just don't love the game like that
it is go out i feel like i sort of kind
of feel he's thinking about legacy and
he i like like he fancies himself ali or
something exactly
sure like ali or
[ __ ] who's somebody else who did it but
uh
or kaepernick per se so it's like he can
sacrifice oh i'm gonna take this 186
million dollar hit because i fought for
close
yeah i don't think it's a cause that
people are really going to be like yo
but
this is the same guy who said the earth
is flat so it's like he is like
delusional
i think that's what i was trying to say
like i i could see that i don't think
that people will look at it that way
yeah you're saying that
he thinks of himself yes he's delusional
enough to go this is this matters he
also apparently protested with the
dakota access pipeline americans
apparently he's part native american we
aren't we all like with this part native
american thing is his uh everything i'm
a little naked
only because you're scottish
that's the first native americans
stop
are they not didn't we have the same
[ __ ] outfits
face paint
oh
no feathers though you guys didn't have
feathers we didn't have animals with
feather we had wool
we had wool we had sheep a bunch of wool
in my pubes from pounding that purse
no but uh but yeah i think i think
that's a good point and i think he's
searching for something and it's
fascinating because and i'll be
completely transparent here uh the more
uh
successful or money i get the less i
care about uh things yeah i think when
you have nothing those things really
bother you yeah and uh then you start to
get something and
like you see aoc say some dumb [ __ ] and
then
i i'll go up to my roof and i'll be like
yeah it's i have a roof
dude i mean like but before you don't
have that right you have [ __ ] four
roommates or something like that and
you're just stewing you're angry and
you're like oh what's up and i and
there's comedically i wish that wasn't
the case because for comedy it works way
better the edge helps the edge really
[ __ ] helps to like think you really
[ __ ] care about these things like
there's a reason why dave chapelle's
been talking about [ __ ] for last
three specials it's like well what else
is bothering them that's a fun nothing
else bothering right
right you do whatever you want you have
all the money in the world you travel
wherever you want wherever you go people
say you're great there's one group of
people it's like this guy's annoying and
you're holding on to it you want you
can't lose that
is that that's why this is last night
maybe you lose it maybe you don't lose
it but like that is the group that's
continually poking yeah the bear you're
like okay well i'm going to talk about
the things that that bother me yeah you
know i'm going to talk about the things
that are causing an issue like i
completely get that so when i see a guy
who's rich and successful like kyrie and
he's still worried about a [ __ ] well
over here and i'm like oh this guy's
tormented like this guy's got something
wrong yeah because when you have all
that money and all the power personally
to affect your community and all these
communities and you're still like
causing a fuss yeah there's something up
here that a deep-seated
um
issue problem void
that you're trying to fill you know what
you can do with 168 million dollars is
uh pay the people who have lost their
jobs because they're protesting the
vaccine that's a good one too you know
what i mean like you really want to help
buddy dude money helps that's the thing
yeah
sacrificing money to help it never
really works
money helps money's great sac yeah yeah
that money helps the most that's that
jay-z [ __ ] that's the win-win right how
can i help the poor one of them like
money helps
money now if by sacrificing you can
raise even more money and then do more
help sure
colin kaepernick wasn't gonna make
enough money playing football where he
could do the help that he did by
protesting
he just wasn't he wasn't gonna get big
contracts nobody really thought that he
was that good he lost it yeah thought he
lost he'd probably make 10 million
dollars something like that black lives
matter the movement
has made hundreds of millions of dollars
so he actually made more money
sacrificing i don't think people are
going to be donating that much money to
the kyrie i'm not going to wear a mask
or get vaccinated
yeah
yeah the world is flat foundation
[Applause]
you